However,
1911,
the last of the Yani Indians
issue was discovered in Oroville.
I can't believe I remember all this in
Oroville, California, northern California.
And there was a bounty
on Indians back then.
You could shoot a man Indian and
get 25 bucks. You should 1911. Yup.
They had bounties on them. Instead of
shooting this, Yani does last Indian,
they called the local sheriff and Nate
took issue into custody and they called,
uh, some scientists and uh, uh,
Pelon theologists I'm from
California University by the name of,
uh, Saxton Pope. And Saxton
pope came and studied each.
She as a, as a aboriginal
last pope, a pope and young.
That's right.
And then he contacted his buddy art young,
who also studied in that genre and they
discovered EEG and they were fascinated
by his stealthy awareness of the
wilderness in his archery control with his
funny little style of shooting the bull
with his thumb and getting close and
doing,
uh,
ice cold river bathing before the hunt
to cleanse himself to be worthy of the
beast.
So Fred bear witnessed the film that
Pope and young eventually made of them
becoming consumed with the
mystical flight of the Arrow.
Now this was in the twenties and thirties,
and they put a newsreel out when all
over the country and showed this newsreel
of hunting with the bone Arrow by Saxton
Pope and art young shooting grizzly
bears in Yosemite and going to Africa
fill in lines full of arrows because they
weren't really as good as he,
she.
So they'd fling a lot arrows and
these animals pretty relaxed,
almost tame because they'd never
been hunted like that before.
And so Fred bear come from
Pennsylvania around that time, um,
to work at the Fomo company,
a building cabinets for the new radio
they just invented and the wood dashboards
for the Ford Motor Company.
And he was also making bows a handmade.
You would an or Osage orange bows in his
little archery shop with Nels grumbly.
I can't believe I
remembered Nell's grumbling,
one of the greatest boy years of all time.
So my dad got the archery bug because
Fred defied the trend of easier hunting,
easier, long range. You didn't have to be
very stealthy shooted here at 500 yards.
They don't even know you're there.
I have to do is be a discipline Marchmen
which is a discipline and a great
accomplishment unto itself.
And it was a new challenge for
long range ballistic capability.
Will Pope and young and
a handful Fred bear,
Nell's grumbly went and saw
this newsreel of these guys,
these doctors, these, uh,
professors hunting all of the world with
these handmade bows and fed was already
into it and he was,
how be damn this,
I didn't realize you could do that.
And so now people after seeing the pope
and young newsreel started asking Fred
to make bows and it spits spreads.
So we started the bear archery company,
late twenties,
early thirties.
And he moved to Graylin up in the northern
part of Michigan with a wilderness
was,
and they had cut down all the trees.
So there was this new growth of ideal
wildlife habitat because not many animals
can live in an old growth
forest and our tool.
But you need low level escape sanctuary
in browse that the animals can access.
And so Fred was now promoting our tree
in Michigan, one, all the, uh, uh,
national field archery championship
championships along with an Marston.
It's awesome.
And so my dad was a follower because
he'd come back from World War II and he
needed that escape.
He needed that cleansing to
get away from that horror,
which is why they never talked about it.
And so we go up north every year,
October 1st, the Nugen family
and the Ford station wagon.
And I have my little bone
Arrow with the suction cups.
And I shoot stuffed animals off the couch.
But my dad would walk the woods with his
real bow and we'd stop at this little,
uh, brick shack that said, bear
archery. And I had no idea.
And so I was already into bows and arrows
shooting all the time. I was obsessed.
I was an downriver every day. No baseball,
no football, no hockey, bows and arrows,
bows, murals, critters.
I think I had the songbird world's
slam by the time I was eight. And, uh,
and so now I'm meeting this tall,
lanky gentleman named Fred Bear.
And it didn't register with me until I
started seeing him on the cover of true
magazine and sporting magazines and,
and life magazine with a Grizzly bear
and an elephant and a tiger and a lion in
the newsreels. And I'm going, I'm shooting
river rats, which is so thrilling.
I can't even describe it. And
here's this long, lanky, tall,
lanky guy that was building bows in this
Russ rustic shop in northern Michigan
on my way to my favorite thing in life,
October 1st opening day of archery season
as a six, seven, eight year old boy.
And we'd have chocolate milk and
Cherry Pie with this Fred bear guy.
Now it's registering. This is the
Chuck Berry of [inaudible]. This is it.
This is the guy.
So I became a namerd with him and he
was kind to me and he'd show me stuff,
but I got to hang out with them as I grew.
By the time I was 16 we moved to Chicago,
was my dad got transferred,
but I got to visit with Fred bear
at least every other October.
Never hunted with them. And I
am now. I started Amboy. Dukes.
I had already had a great band when the
battle of the bands and Michigan with
the Lord's, we opened up for the Supremes
and the Beau Brummels at Cobo Hall. Wow.
And so now I'm in Chicago shooting
my bow and Arrow all the time.
Started the Amboy dukes
playing like a madman,
graduated in 67 went back to Michigan
that two years later and immediately went
up to grading.
We're now,
there's this huge cathedral bear archery
had Fred bear is like that dude is like
the sporting dude because he taught
the long range marksman that there's an
intimacy,
there's a a better learning process in
more important lesson to not kill the
animal but to understand your relationship
with the animal and to try to use
those God given gifts.
I mentioned a moment ago to penetrate
the otherwise impenetrable defense system
of game cause they are
sneaky, elusive, crafty.
God made them to get away from
guitar players with sharp sticks.
And so this caught on because people go,
you know,
I killed my deer every year with my 30 30
now with the 30 out six and Roy breath,
whether it be long range,
I wonder if I'm a bad ass enough to get
close to a deer with a bow and arrow.
So it caught on like wildfire
and they made the first,
Fred got the first legal
season in Michigan,
the Alagan state park on November 1st,
1947 where George Nichols,
my buddy got the first legal buck in
Michigan with the bone Arrow on that
morning. And so I knew these are the guys
who hang with, these are the founders.
These were the you were,
I was at the Concord bridge of our tree.
And so Fred had embraced me and it was
real suspicious of the long haired hippy
looking, you know, rocking
Maniac Motor City Madman.
But all of his friends would
not, no, he's not into drugs.
He's in fact he's anti and he's always
promoting our trash out my bone arrow on
stage forever. Now it should. Flaming
Arrows at skulls and a big illegal,
I think it was a felony, a
big Turkey vulture. I had
stopped, but it looked great.
Backlit, you know, and I'd shoot
that fucker off this amps at night.
People didn't know whether
to shit or go blind
is is wild man screen the bird lands.
We
make it all this outrageous racket.
I come up with a bow and
Arrow and a flaming Arrow
and blow up a Turkey vulture.
What more do you want?
And so Fred got
pass the insanity of the
fear factor of rock and roll.
And he finally admitted to me, he said,
every sporting good show I go to Ted,
all the young people,
anybody under 30 all they want
to know is if I know Ted Nugent,
because that was the first
time they ever saw bone arrow.
And they read my you my
interviews about the, the spirit,
the cleansing of escaping the insanity
of whatever your job description might
be. Mine beaten, maniacal rock and roll.
I need to shut the fuck up,
take a deep breath,
get my bone arrow,
letting my guitars breed
head back to the woods.
And live and and remember who I am and
what I'm here for and I never killed a
deer. I was a little too uppity and we
didn't know what we were doing back then.
You have too uppity, you think? What
do you mean? I just, I'm high energy.
So you had to, I do. I write
about too loud. I mean,
I could walk.
I learned from,
I learned walk toe first and I learned
to go around anything you instead of
stepping over and to stay in the shadows.
So I knew of the maneuvers,
but coming out of a tour and played 350
nights a year and then you get a couple
of days off during November
and you get the bone arrow.
It's hard to go from that
to total silence. Yes.
But you know what Joe, what? I've
mastered it. Well, I know. Yeah.
I finally,
I mean I did buy it and you might have
six long time by the 60s I don't know
about masters. You'll never master
it, but I have mastered transition.
What do you say when people like that?
One of the arguments about hunting that
people bring up is why would you use in
a bow and Arrow bow and
arrows not as effective. If
you wanted to kill something,
you should use a gun.
There's people that don't hunt that think
that hunting should only be one thing
and it should only be
killing the animal from me.
Whereas I think that someone who hunts
definitely kills the animal from me.
There's more,
there's more to the whole thing and do
you ever seen me expound on that fun
sport meet trophy.
You can't hunt without having
fun or you won't do it.
It's fun to challenge yourself.
It's fun to get up into those aren't
able to have a problem with that word.
They can kiss my ass if it wasn't fun.
None of us would do it.
I understand your, your your take
on it, they can kiss, kiss your ass,
but you, it means something to
you. It's not as simple as like,
fuck you,
this is just how I'm going to do deep fun
is being the greatest basketball three
point shooter. Isn't it fun? It must
be discipline. He went. But it's,
it's always fun.
It's because it's invigorating and the
bow hunting is more invigorating because
it's so difficult. So disorder
lining, possible fun sport.
Why don't think sport hunting is good?
You shouldn't have sport.
How can you hot without sport?
Well,
don't you think that there's just
too many of these words are poisoned.
There's like trophy hunting by eight
at term. Can't hunt without a trophy.
You know what I have on my wall to
my northern cabin. You're going to,
you already are inclined to love me,
but now really going to say
you're going for you to,
but fuck me right here on the whoa.
That's not love.
Well it's a metaphorically speaking.
That is for some of my buddies. Anyhow,
so I'm the wall of my cabin in
northern Michigan is my first kill.
November 15th, 1969 with my dad's
pre 67 bottles. Stuck button. Buck.
Do you hear the story? Yeah. And I
took it to the taxidermist and I said,
I want this mind when he said here to
mount this, you'll, yeah, no buck button.
Button. Buck is a font of the year with
the, has little buttons on his forehead,
which is illegal deer with a doe tag.
And I had that year and I said,
it's a buck feel.
You have to feel on the head,
make sure it is a buck is it's such
a little guy and it's illegal dear.
And it's a delicious deer
there. Deer, the years of fun.
That's why we have this hunting
season in the fall because now they're
independent. They're not there
have been weaned. They're,
they're independent animals. In
fact, the, the button bucks are,
they're acids get kicked by their
mother to throw him out of the herd,
get the hell out of the way for more
breeding, which is what I do. And uh,
and so I have that button buck mounted.
Well,
who's going to tell me
that's not a trophy?
Tha Tha Tha Tha experiences the
memories, the clothes, the bullets,
the day, the sunrise, the crows,
the sandhill cranes, the birds,
the movement,
the anticipation.
And I got backstraps, I had
fun, ultimate discipline,
challenge, sport, ultimate
meet, ultimate protein,
the purest, most organic before
it was even hip. And if you,
I dare you to tell me that button.
Buck is not a trophy. I got,
I have wood chucks mounted.
I got a shot.
I would chuck in the eye with my grandson.
I have,
I have squirrels. Mud. He's always a
trophy. Mounted a squirrel. I sure I'm,
I'm the squirrels czar. Um, you know,
when you, when you first started out,
you killed that first squirrel.
That's exciting stuff.